I love this man I had so many great
years that I cherished sitting at the
other end of a set or through a two-way
talk on NFL Network he is now the
general manager of the Las Vegas Raiders
he is my buddy mike Mayock how are you
Michael
okay the NATO minute I'm fine how's
everybody in the family everybody
healthy are pretty good
everything knock on wood knock on wood
everybody's good how about you guys
same here same here you know family's
good and the show family here we're all
healthy and safe and socially distant
enough to come here to work every day
and do this so you know I appreciate you
you callin in today so I guess first
order of business is how was this draft
Mike I mean how was it for you to
conduct it it was so obviously out of
the ordinary yeah I mean it obviously
there were challenges out there for all
32 teams and that's all that really
matters and to our organization was that
we're all on equal footing and I think
that was important and so starting from
the time where we had to leave leave the
facilities all the way through the draft
itself you know we put a lot of pressure
off on our IT people our analytics
people our video people and I thought
everybody just rate rose to the occasion
we got the work done that was necessary
to evaluate and then I thought draft
weekend went off without a hitch and you
start talking about how many people were
remote and how many connections had to
be made and it's just I thought I didn't
see a whole lot of it on television but
what I was told was everything went
seamlessly and you know we got through
it and I think every team felt really
good about it rich well I spoke to
two-year colleagues this week already in
Howey Roseman in Philly and John Elway
yesterday in Denver and both of them
seemed to think that it did take a while
for everyone get used to it and how he
in particular said he thought that there
were fewer trades maybe Thursday and
Friday because people were still kind of
getting used to used to it Elway said at
one point it was difficult to have a
private conversation he kind of had to
step away from zooming and all of that
stuff and that Saturday is when things
felt a little bit normal would you agree
with that assessment
uh you know what Thursday night we were
on the phone a lot and I don't really
believe the technology or the remoteness
of the situation affected us at all and
I'll tell you four five or six straight
nights prior to the draft we were
practicing you know we were we were
zooming we had our trade guys in
different parts of the country we had
our scouts calling in and trying to
overwhelm our phone lines just to make
sure we could handle both the phone
lines and the video lines and it worked
out pretty well so I you know there
could I think the one thing rich you
kind of felt like once you got to a
certain point left on the clock you had
to hurry because it wasn't like
everybody was in the same room together
if you're trying to make a trade and you
were down low about two and a half
minutes three minutes you were trying to
get it done because you still had the
facilitation go through the trade line
to the NFL you had to call the kid that
you were trading for drafting you know
there was a lot going on that typically
would happen a lot easier but I I feel
like the reality of it it went off
without a hitch and then I also just you
know from our years together I knew that
everything's an evaluation for you how
would you evaluate Gruden's handling of
the IT cuz a lot of people thought he
might be the guy who talks into his
mouth and not you know figure that stuff
out how was how was Gruden in your
evaluation I mean we're two dinosaurs
you know we're now about an hour apart
and we're you know at first the week
before John was like I don't want to be
on that boom thing I want to be on a
phone with you Mike and then you do all
the zoom stuff and then we had a couple
proc practice mock drafts that went off
without a hitch and he was like that
that's not too bad that was kind of cool
and you know John gets the point he
starts to embrace it and then he's
really funny
so it went well that's good because I
guess Callie I know could've just
stepped in at any point in time you know
no doubt about that mike Mayock ER on
the Rich Eisen show let's get into
evaluation we had again Elway on
yesterday he said that the Broncos ran
several mock drafts and not a single one
of their mock drafts had rugs being
taken by you why did you choose rugs out
of all the wide receivers at your
disposal potentially well you know the
respect quote that group of the top
three wideouts that everybody wanted to
talk about Judy rugs and CD lamb and we
loved all three of them and I felt like
John and our staff could take advantage
of the distinctive talents of all three
because they were very different and at
the end of the day I think the pure
speed of Henry rugs is kind of what
changed things for us and and I think we
felt like we've been for bereft of speed
both vertically and horizontally and
when you get a guy like rug not only
getting the vertical threat to deep
overs the post routes you're also kind
of getting those manufactured touches
the horizontal ones the jet sweeps the
bubble screens when I talked to Nick
Saban and he told me he approaches every
day like he's a walk-on
his work ethic is off the charts he was
a gunner and a jammer on special teams
so we felt like we got in in one body we
got a potential kick returner we got a
gunner jammer we got a guy to stretch
the field vertically and I think even
more important than all that rich
because again I think John could have
used all three of those wide outs to
their highest degree of excellency but
what changed it for us is we felt like
that element of speed would make Josh
Jacobs better would make Darren wall or
better would make everything underneath
better and effectively make our whole
offense better well I mean mind you you
you kept hammering that wide receiver
position as well when you used two of
your three third round selections on on
Lynn Bowden junior and Brian Edwards of
Kentucky and South Carolina respectively
why did you feel the need to keep
hitting that same position Mike well the
reality is for us Lynn Bose was going to
play running back and he at Kentucky it
was kind of cool because his junior year
he caught close to 70 passes in the SEC
who was the top one
slot receivers in the country and then
his senior year the quarterback got hurt
and they moved him the quarterback and
he rushed for 1213 hundred yards in the
sec as a running quarterback slash
Wildcat guy so we kind of envisioned
Lynn Bowden as first and foremost
primarily a running back as he learns
how to pass protect and do all the
different jobs demanded of them by that
position I think the cool thing about em
rich is he becomes at what John calls a
joker an ability to play running back
slot why we can use him we could line up
him up in a wildcat in the red zone
so we envision Lynn Bowden doing a
variety of jobs for us but primarily
he'll be a running back and then Brian
Edwards to us we had him with a high
second-round grade and he was sitting
there at 81 and just couldn't pass up on
that and he's a big bodied tough guy the
all-time leading passer receiver at
South Carolina
he started over 40 games in the SEC so
we were kind of blown away both by his
productivity and his consistency in the
best conference in the country I guess
that seems like that was a facet about
this draft of where the wide receivers
mike mike Mayock by the way of the las
vegas raiders here on the Rich Eisen
show is that you you you were getting
guys in rounds with grades much higher
than what you were getting them would
you agree in terms of everything the
years that we were working together to
this year deepest wide receiver draft
period no I think every team in the
league went into it knowing that there
was quality at the top and depth
throughout and you know I think
typically the the average was 12 or 13
wide outs have gone in the first three
rounds over the last five years and I
think 12 went in the first two rounds
which set a record in the mod modern
draft so certainly every team in the
league felt like that was the case rich
there were guys in the fourth and fifth
round that I was salivating over that
were put that were wide outs that
typically would be third round guys so
so yeah I the that position this year we
thought had the best quality up top in
the depth throughout let me just circle
back briefly to your second first round
so
election the last of the Khalil Mack
first-rounders that Gruden placed in
your expert hands to turn into human
beings damon Arnett now part of the
conversation about our net leading in
and on draft night as well was his tape
in the biggest game of the year against
Clemson did not suit him very well I'm
sure you saw a similar tape and maybe
thought a different thing about this
young man or saw somebody who you know
fought through a difficult night on on
occasion what did you see on his film
what we saw was in 35 starts at Ohio
State we thought he was most competitive
cornerback in this draft as far as the
guy that showed up every week competed
tackled he can play inside he can play
outside he can play the right side he
can play the left side he played most of
this season with a cast on his arm we
thought that if you just what we're
looking for rich willing when John and I
sit in a room by ourselves and we talk
about what are we trying to construct
here and we talked about competitive
tough guys that come to work every day
because they love it not just because
they're getting paid for it and that's
named in our net so to us when you're in
our division and you're playing the
Chiefs
twice a year you mentioned John Elway
you know they drafted wide outs they
drafted tight inserted everybody's
trying to get faster and more dynamics
to compete with the chief so in our
division you better line up you better
be fast you better be competitive you
better be tough and you better not
flinch and we don't think this kid will
flinch alright a few minutes I have left
with you let me hit you on some 20/20
questions and we hope for a full season
to use the phrase of your head coach
knock on what if you're with me we're
all knocking wood on that so house Abram
is he ready to roll is he ready to go
kid oh yeah I mean almost feel like
we've got another first-round pick here
he played one game last year hurt the
shoulder he's a hundred percent I taught
them all time and he is fired up and
ready to go okay last time we spoke was
at the combine I tried to walk through
the side door rear entry door whatever
you want to try and get you to talk
about Tom Brady
sniff that out a mile away and moved in
a different direction
so now Here I am knocking on the door
about the the Mariota acquisition for
you and how you know everything that's
old is new again we're seeing how
Rodgers is in kind of in the role of a
Favre and I spoke to Brett about that
yesterday and people are thinking maybe
Mariota could be in the role of
Tannehill with Derek Carr in the role of
Mariota going into this season how do
you how would you handle that as a
narrative mic right first and foremost
our cars our quarterback and John and I
love what he did last year and he
completed 70% of his passes and he had a
great quarterback rating and do we think
he can get better sure you're three in
Gruden's offense we expect them to get
better but when you're looking at a guy
like Mariota
the cool thing for John and I when we
had the Mariota conversation is remember
rich we were both in television in Mario
this draft year John and I so if you're
Marcus Mariota and you want to know what
Mike may have begun routing think of you
check the 10 check the tape just like
you a turn now they're evaluating John
and I and you know the it's really kind
of cool because we had some great
conversations with Marcus about that he
knows we believe in both Marcus Mariota
the person more importantly and Marcus
Mariota the football player and you know
I think we've got to rebuild him a
little bit he was beat up you had to get
some surgery after the season you got to
clean up some technique from the ground
up I think John is the right guy for
that and we just could not resist adding
that kind of talent to our quarterback
well I guess that is that the question
du jour as well because that's what I
talked about with Harry Roseman the
other day is that when you choose
somebody and Packers having that
conversation my lord are they having
that conversation right now when you've
got an already installed quarterback a
veteran somebody who is associated with
this team somebody who's well paid to be
associated with that team and then you
have another quarterback it's your job
as general manager to fill out a roster
and make sure that that position is
taken care of should that quarterback
and
be able to make the snap or falter and I
guess that that's the question Mike is
how do you view the role of quarterback
number two in your job well we believe
that where we are as an offense right
now is we ought to be very competitive
offensively we ran the ball really well
we've got a big strong offensive line we
augmented the receiver position in the
draft and free agency we feel like we
should be a big strong powerful tough
and more dynamic team this year and I
think our job John and mine is to ensure
that if something were to happen to dark
that we continue to be that same team
and we think Marcus gives us the best
opportunity to do just that
all right Mike I appreciate the time you
know and I tried to get your your home
draft setup from you you know many of
your colleagues applied you are the only
one that took a shot from outside the
window and and and that's all I got can
you at least describe and then you're
like I know what you meant
I'm by the way I'm putting that text up
on the screen right now when I called
you out I know what you meant with four
dots I mean what I mean can you at least
describe it there were two reasons there
number one was that in a little dining
room and I rented Alameda house that I
have five white boards surrounding me
with close to a thousand magnets and if
I had taken a shot anywhere in that room
you would have seen a white board with a
bunch of names on it and then I just
figured I'd have a little did you see
Belle did you at least see Bella checks
did you see his Nantucket set up did you
li see that on ESPN Mike I think I did
and I was happy for Bill man he's all he
had was a laptop on a table it looked
like to me and a dog and his dog Nike
the dog he's feeding treats look he's a
much smarter guy than I am I need
thousands of pieces of paper and you
know I mean builds amazing and you know
as you know
yes respect I have for him I know so
your your
school you're like post-its and
whiteboards and grease boards and
magnets you're just I should be
surprised you always had like like
third-grade scholastic black and white
charcoal notebook that you brought with
all your notes sitting next to my
left-handed scratched because I used to
have to take because I'm left-handed and
right you had to go through that
three-hole binder thing you know and
then it looks like a claw when you're
writing but yeah that was our Lady of
Lourdes and I brought it with me and the
funny thing is rich and you'll see this
as your kids get older yes is that my
kids crushed me for for those books that
I carry around like notes in and now I
look at both of them as grown adults and
they both carry around the same things
in their bags look at right now you pay
it forward Mike that's the way it works
thanks to the time Mike you take care of
yourself stay healthy okay and we'll
chat soon
Sam you and your family thank right back
at you that's Mike Mac my buddy hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here